[Music]
he needs a bed he needs a home
don't know what to do anymore that's
disgraceful you know these are children
that have gone through these so they're
going through it again it's not right it
can be really really stressful sometimes
you don't sleep sometimes you cry
throughout lockdown social workers have
been trying to keep track of thousands
of vulnerable children so she haven't
seen her mom since last year it is a
world which we rarely get to see from
the inside we're quite dogged very
persistent so if we do have concerns we
won't let that lie but two weeks our
cameras have followed social workers at
Britain's the biggest Child Protection
Department at stake the lives of
children they need as a mom and that is
sad because so too is what kids need in
a bed and we see families that have
fallen apart
built back up again I'm gonna miss you
we're gonna miss you too but social
workers fear that a storm is coming
become a service code I think we will
see an increase in referrals come
September because children will start to
tell their stories the additional money
that government's given them to local
authorities so far does not cover all of
the additional costs and that will mean
less support for families just at the
point when they need it most
[Music]
Ramsgate in the district of Thanet in
East Kent
Thanet has the highest rates of child
poverty in the whole of the county with
almost a quarter of children here living
below the bread line and with households
locked down for months big issues like
drink and drugs finances relationships
festered behind closed doors poverty was
a big driver of some of the issues
around lockdown we have a child
population of around 350,000 we have
around 10,000 children with the social
worker so this year we might get as many
as 50,000 contacts and referrals at our
front door I was really worried when
lockdown started knowing that mom was
pregnant and we hope we have provided a
lot of support this is the Children's
Services Department of Kent County
Council it's the biggest Child
Protection Department in the country at
the moment we are operating on a
skeleton staff with the majority staff
working virtually in at home make any
clear academic progress or art in mind
behind every phone conversation is
potentially a child at risk she does
have Instagram and she follows her mom
and she gets quite upset with some
things mom's posting so she's posting
nights out spending money on alcohol and
during the pandemic it's become
worryingly quiet we have seen a drop in
the referrals coming through our front
door which makes us concerned because
there are quite a few venerable children
now who have no professionals involved
with their lives and we can't see what
their lived experiences is day to day
and there's a stark warning about how
busy things could be about to get the
worst case scenario is it could be as
much as two hundred and fifty percent
increase on what we would normally see
in September so I'm very worried about
that I'm very worried about our
resources being stretched a breaking
point in September if we're not careful
and that's a concern when the safety of
children is at stake
in the early hours of the 5th of April
at the height of the lockdown 11 month
old Casey Lou Kennedy was found dead at
her home in Ramsgate there was noted
bruising to both sides of her forehead
this obviously just needed to be
explored there was no previous history
to raise concern for the baby because of
lockdown it took six weeks to establish
the full facts around how Casey died
this is where the impacts of covetous
has really hit as hard actually because
I think the most important thing is
getting in alongside families
experiencing what it's like you know in
in their homes after investigating
social services concluded that there was
nothing suspicious about the baby's
death the bruising was due to a common
bump to the head and baby Casey had died
in her sleep after moving into a
position where she couldn't breathe you
accept them support for you and your
children
and you're able to recognize the impact
on the children and take steps weeks of
delays has taken its toll on the family
and I just feel I'm being blamed as I'm
a single mom of five in a Housing
Association house in a time when
actually I need support not being
touched got a lot of respect for family
and just to go through this in such dire
situations a bereavement in the family
tied in with the Cova crisis it's just
so unexpected it's it's a minefield
really to get through to get the right
support to explore the emotions and it's
had such a knock-on impact for the
family
I think we have to do sex toys just to
get through the day but taking a moment
to stop and think about it you do it's
it can be overwhelming we just want to
do the right thing
[Music]
some cases lasts just a few weeks others
span many years
Heinrich's net ler is only a year out of
training but has already dealt with a
very complex case during lockdown the
removal of a child from its parent
Heinie's meeting 31 year old mum Gemma
she's had five children and each one has
been taken off her the latest a baby boy
put up for adoption just two weeks ago
when Gemma invited individuals in her
property there were drugs and alcohol
abuse and some that did pose risks to
children sometimes the men in Gemma's
life sexually abused her and her
children losing my children it had
finally made me realize that it is time
to change and I should have changed
years ago before all this happened but
there's been a development since Henreid
last saw Gemma she has a new partner and
she's pregnant I want the baby to come
home I find it hard to trust anyone let
alone social workers and it scares me
everyday that I'm gonna go through all
this change that I'm trying to prove
that I've done and go through the whole
pregnancy just to have it snatched away
from me again can you describe to me
what it's like to have child after child
taking off you
having a child removed from you care
it's basically like your heart being
ripped out and stamps on repeatedly and
to have it keep happening it makes me
feel less of a person and it makes me
feel like I'm not a mum and that I've
just failed them children and it makes
me feel like I've basically given birth
to them and just giving them to people
that need children I don't feel like I'm
a mum I feel like I'm a surrogate person
that gives birth to children and hasn't
taken away is this time different no but
ultimately this is about a young child
that we want to be happy safe and
leading a fulfilled life
one of the most common types of
referrals during the pandemic has been
due to a rise in cases of domestic
violence often with small children
caught in the middle in 2015 Cheryl
green and Wayne Anderson had a baby boy
called Bobby five months later he died
from a heart defect the effect on the
family was devastating
stop drinking arguing with my partner
getting a bit physical violence like
smashing things out you come back and it
be drunk and I'd say to him well you
can't be drunk around the children like
the child you need to sort of stay away
social workers were called to assess how
all this impacted on Wayne and Cheryl's
remaining son and whether he was at risk
today is a really positive day actually
for us here we're hoping to have a child
in need meeting with a family and end
our involvement with them at Marea I you
satisfied the safety goals are achieved
for the family after months of work
Wayne and Cheryl can now say goodbye to
their social workers where we are now is
completely different to where we started
I honestly believe that we won't have
any more referrals coming in for this
family because we found the root of the
problem I'm gonna miss you
we're gonna miss you too we're really
gonna miss you I've really enjoyed
working with you in the beginning it was
hard you didn't want to know me they
made us into better people and our life
so much better now than what it was a
year ago
Wayne is so different it is amazing bye
mommy go among the success stories
social workers say they're worried about
the long-term effects of the pandemic on
children
three-year-old Charlie and his mum Sarah
are sleeping on a relative sofa because
they're homeless and the pandemic is
making things worse
are you alright Emily yeah good thank
you is he feeling a bit poorly Sarah has
a 9 you
some that was removed from her care and
is living with grandparents she's
currently got a three year old son
living with her and she's pregnant with
twins and they are subject to a child
protection plan Sarah was thrown out of
her accommodation after an allegation
she was using drugs she's appealing but
because of kovat that's not being heard
until December her twins are due in
October they feel they have to take
people's kids and stuff away and that's
how I feel I'm Emily at the minute very
soon that gonna take my unborn kids off
me and everything and that is the truth
I'm really really stressed about that
I'm not sleeping over because I feel
like this is the only thing they've got
on me is this I just felt like winging
the social and saying you know what find
my children adopted favors what kids
need in a bed my biggest fear is that
things deteriorate and we're in a
position where we might have to start
legal proceedings the end result of that
would be that the children are removed
from her care that that is not my aim
and that is not the goal my hope is that
we can support her to secure appropriate
accommodation we can get a grip on her
mental health and support her through
that and ensure that she provides
consistent and safe care to the children
the number of children been taken into
care stands at a 10-year high and
there's a fear that the pandemic could
cause a surge in demand for social
services so a nice feeling waking up
every day and thinking I wonder how my
children are today
Naomi became separated from her three
children when her mental health got too
much and she couldn't cope it was dark
it was empty it was an empty feeling
being away from my children hello it's
just me
Georgina Linda has been Naomi's social
worker for the past 18 months with one
aim to get her reunited with a 14 year
old son Owen now lockdown is easing she
can visit both of them because mum and
son are back together only think that
when children go into care yeah they
come home no they think that's the first
day that Irene came back for a visit
I was jumping up and down in excitement
and as soon as I open the door and see
her in face I've got the massive hug big
massive hug from him and it was just
absolutely lovely I just missed that hug
so much never knowing whether or not
you're going to see your children again
is it's quite scary but also be reunited
with your child is such a wonderful
experience it's kind of a bit of a
miracle happy moment that I'm here it
feels like something's happened and it's
really good unlike a lot of the other
things that have happened through my
life in September all children of school
age should return to their classrooms
some will have good stories to tell
others won't
before the pandemic councils were
warning of a three billion pound black
hole in child services as by the end of
last year thousands more children were
requiring protection fast forward a few
months and government budgets have been
torn up to cope with the pandemic and no
one really knows how that will
impact the funding of these services and
when the cuts in the future are
inevitable the government says it's
provided support for councils to cope
June kovat as well as enabling
vulnerable children to attend school but
is it enough it looks as though
withstanding kind of on the precipice of
a really huge problem come September but
the government needs to be more visible
on this issue they need to help us and
support us to do the work that society
wants done but he's often hidden from
view and unseen by the public the
additional money of the government's
given to local authorities so far does
not cover all of the additional costs
and that'll mean less support for
families just at the point
you